Exactly. To all the cute little 20 something girls being like,
let them do for be, cause we'll still be having babies
and we'll be raising babies and will bitch.
Some of us did have those babies,
realized the bullshit we were participating in,
left that shit, and now we're raising four babies in this world
to believe what we believe.
Just like you can radicalize your fucking babies,
there's people on the other side doing the same fucking thing.
They're learning from me as well.
Don't think that all feminists don't have kids.
Some of us are making up for our childless sisters. Okay?
I had four kids
and believe that all of them are gonna be raised to be kind hearted,
empathetic people who understand community and love.
There's many of us out there.